hi folks like tomorrow I said I'm Ray
hondurani and today I'm going to be
talking about how to maximally paralyze
the entire pandas API
people love pandas it's flexible and
easy to use with over 600 apis that
allow for rapid prototyping which leads
to its wide adoption the problem is
tennis isn't scale it requires already
to be in memory and single threaded
which means that the runtime can
increase dramatically even on simple
pipelines when the size of your data
increases
enter modin a distributed drop-in
replacement for pandas but before we get
into the details of how we Implement
modem let's take a step back and talk
about why data frames are interesting
what is it about datagrams that make
people love them so much
the short answer is that data frames
offer a wide variety of operators from
different data modalities combined into
one easy to visualize representation of
tabular data in other words like we said
earlier data frames are flexible and
really begin to see this flexibility
when you take a look at what a data
frame is and what it can do
formally a data frame is an array of
tabular data along with a set of column
labels that are often semantic in nature
a set of row labels that are similarly
semantic in nature and a schema that
Maps the name of each column to the type
of data it contains like arrays data
frames have an implicit ordering on
position and support positional random
axis and the transpose operator from
linear algebra but like databases they
also suppose they also support lay
low-based access
data frame schemas are flexible say your
co-worker gives you a CSV that they want
you to analyze you don't have to spend
your time going to the CSV and manually
determining how many columns there are
what the name of each column is and what
the type of each column is as most if
not all pandas users will know pandas
will automatically infer a schema on
your data frame during ingest and if you
decide that schema is too restrictive or
maybe you want to change types or add
columns you can always change that
during your workflow fairly easily and
pretty rapidly
so if everyone wants a data frame so
much why are we having this conversation
now data friends are first introduced to
the python ecosystem more than 10 years
ago so why don't we see more scalable
data frame systems
and the answer lies in three key
challenges
the first ironically is their massive
API pandas has over 240 unique operators
which makes it very hard to optimize
each by hand
the second has to do with parallel
execution as data science practitioners
will know data frame operations often
involve accessing data in different ways
whether it be along the rows on the
columns or along the cells each of these
three types of data axis requires
different parallelization schemes in
order to effectively optimize them
the third has to do with variable
database data shape databases are tone
scheming they have many neuros and few
columns thanks to the transfers operator
data frames can be not only tall and
skinny but they can also be wide and
short which induces additional
complexion in the system
on the modern team we had three key
insights to help us resolve some of
these challenges for all these
challenges the first is our data frame
decomposition rules that allow us to
effectively partition data frames the
second is the principle of mandated
Independence that allows us to more
efficiently compute data frame
operations
and the third is our data from algebra a
minimal set of 16 operators that we can
compose to form any data frame query in
the next couple of slides we'll talk a
little bit about each of these
approaches and how they help us resolve
the challenges in the previous slide
First Data frame decomposition why do we
care when we're doing a data frame
operation say we're taking the mean of
all the rows we can parallelize that
along the rows if we're doing an
operation like the mean of electrical
columns we can parallelize line of
columns but we can't do the opposite I
mean you could do a two-phase reduce but
for the sake of this example let's say
we want to paralyze on the columns it
wouldn't really make sense to do a mean
operation along the rows parallels
across the columns each operation on a
data frame has a certain level of
parallelism whether it beyond the rows
on the columns or along the cells and
using our data frame decomposition rules
we can partition our data frame
effectively to take advantage of that
native parallelization
so let's take a look at this data frame
when we talk about data frames we often
talk about two axes the row axis and the
column axis they function pretty
similarly to the X and Y axis in the
Cartesian plane the arrow axis runs top
to bottom and the column access runs
left to right we can decompose along
each axis and that just means to split
the data frame into Data frames that
contain one or more elements along that
axis so if I were to do a columnized
decomposition I would take this data
frame and split it up into a list of
data frames where each new data frame
has one or more of the original data
frames columns and all the rows
similarly I could do a real wise
decomposition where I take this data
frame and split it into a list of data
frames that contain one or more of the
rows of the original data frame and all
the columns I can even apply these
decompositions recursively going all the
way down to a cell wise granularity
where each data frame is a single cell
from the original data frame
thanks to this I can more effectively
partition my data frame if I have an
operation that's parallel on the rows I
can use a rowwise decomposition to come
up with a real wise partitioning system
if I have a column parallel operation I
can do a column wise decomposition and
get column parallel up sorry column
partitions if I have a partition that's
parallel along the cells I can
recursively apply column wise and
real-wise decompositions to get Block
partitions which are similar to cell yd
competitions but just not as granular
and this way I can maximize the
parallelism across any operation
our second idea is that I've met data
Independence the key here is that
metadata can be fairly expensive to
compute and also pretty Dynamic it can
change quite frequently but we don't
always need to eagerly maintain metadata
let's talk about a concrete example take
position for example if this were my
data frame in order to compute the
position safe to know that this is row 0
and this is Row one and this is row four
I need to do a join of all the
partitions along the vertical axis
because position is directly tied to how
the data is laid out
right but this can be fairly expensive I
don't always have to do this so say I
have the following pipeline I add one to
every cell in my data frame I select
every other row and then I add two to
the new data frame this operation
doesn't change position this operation
does change position but importantly
this operation not only doesn't change
position but doesn't care about position
so there's no point in eagerly
materializing my position between these
two operations instead I can wait till I
get to an operation perhaps this one
down the line again that does require
position and then materialize my
position allowing me to amortize the
cost of maintaining position across all
these operations
the third idea is our data frame algebra
it's a minimal set of 16 operators that
can be composed to form any data frame
query there's three types of operators
the first are low level operators like
map that physically manipulate data the
second are metadata operators like two
labels death transfer columns from the
array of data into the column label oh
sorry into the row labels or column
labels
and the third is relational operators
that we board from relation algebra like
sort or join our Union
and the neat thing about this is since I
only have 16 operators it's very easy to
well perhaps not very easy but it's a
lot easier to hand optimize each of
these 16 operators than it is to hand
optimize 240 plus operators right and
thinking further if we have queries
there are compositions of these
operators it's a lot easier to
understand how to compose or reorder 16
operators than it is to understand the
relationships between 240 unique
operators
so now we've covered how in theory to
design a system how do we get down to
actually building it right how do we
design a scalable data frame system
the answer lies in modularity Milton has
four layers the first layer is the pet
is the API layer this layer mimics your
favorite API in this case we have the
pandas API but you could always extend
it to have the SQL API or some other API
the next layer is the query compiler
layer this layer translates between the
API layer and our algebra layer it's
basically the
it's basically like a Transformer
basically we go from this really wide
API layer to this very narrow algebra
layer the third layer as we discussed is
our algebra layer and this is the layer
that knows how to do the sort the map
the join but it also understands things
like metadata Independence and lazy
metadata materialization the final layer
is the execution layer and this layer
understands how to talk to execution
engines like rare desk as well as how to
physically manipulate partitions in
order to accomplish what the algebra
wants say we want to do a map over rows
the execution engine understands how to
get the partitions to form row
partitions in order to do that map
so how has been in stack up against the
competition
if you take a look at modem functionally
we can see that we have over 90 coverage
of the pandas API while koalas which is
Sparks Panda's offering and dash data
frame collectively have less than 60
percent
uh if you take a look at performance we
can see that modem consistently
outperforms koalas desk and pandas on
operations like fill and 8 that are
supported by all four and outperforms
pandas and operations like median which
are complicated for koalas and deaths to
do because of their partitioning
strategy
so ultimately what's the end goal here
at Ponder our vision is pandas on
everything not just your favorite
distributed education engine like Ray or
Das or spark but also on top of your
favorite database like postgres or
snowflake
um if folks have any questions please
feel free to reach out to me my contact
info is here and make sure to check out
this QR code uh you can try out a free
trial of uh Ponder our our platform
yeah I can take any questions now folks
have questions
I just realized I was muted I was
talking to you and apologized for that
juggling a lot here Carlos has a
question
um if you can I don't know if you can
see that on the screen yeah that's right
I wasn't trying to see questions yeah so
Carlos is a really good question and the
answer is yeah so uh because we designed
mode into the modular if you could
actually plug in any layer you wanted if
you want to write your own query
compiler you could if you want to write
your own execution engine layer say you
have you know your own execution engine
that you've written you could do that
but uh we're actually at
um at Ponder we hope to have more apis
than just the pandas API perhaps even a
custom mode an API that dictates how we
think data frame should work
foreign
okay
uh so Neil asks can moden be used sorry
tomorrow should I read it no go for it
you're great
awesome thank you yeah so Neil asked can
moden we use out of the box on
databricks and would you recommend using
on databricks that's really your
question Neil and the answer is it kind
of depends on what you mean do you mean
to use the modem on top of data breaks
as in so the way I understand a database
is a notebook offering that it runs um
that basically the front end for its
cluster so could you run mode on top of
that and the answer is yes although we
don't actually have a execution engine
yet for spark so you would have to
basically install maybe Ray or Das or
some other Asian engine on top of your
cluster and run it like that uh so would
I recommend using on data breaks
kind of just to know it really depends
on how like how whether you have the
resources or not to do your own cluster
management so right now our uh Ponder on
top or moden on top of databases is in
the trial stage so that's what that QR
code right here is for
um
sorry can fuel still see my screen
I hope so
um oh yeah so so you do need a
distributed education engine uh to run
mode and if you're not using the trial
that that QR code goes to so you need to
basically stand up your own uh execution
agent on top of that cluster
so whether I would recommend using our
databricks bare metal it kind of depends
on whether or not you have the resources
to manage your own cluster like if you
already use database for your cluster
management then I think it makes sense
to just go with data breaks and stand up
a lightweight Ray or dash cluster on top
of your database cluster uh if you have
it
um
if you if you if you have you know an
AWS account a bunch of credits then
maybe it makes more sense to do that
I hope that answers the question Neil
and feel free to you know reach out to
me on Discord or Twitter or the modern
public slack if you have any follow-ups
uh Jesse you ask what does it not cover
I'm sorry I'm not quite sure I
understand the question
would you could you maybe like clarify a
little bit
we can uh switch and see if they
clarify
so what does it mean uh yeah actually so
that's what that QR code is for actually
uh sorry let me read the question I just
got very excited because this is uh this
is some really awesome work that's been
that Folks at the Ponder team have been
doing uh Mark asked doesn't mean you can
run mode on snowflake as it stands today
the answer is yes uh we're still you
know working on some of the Kinks and
like making sure we can get up to that
90 API support but you know if you go to
this QR code you can sign up for a trial
and you can uh run your records on top
of snowflake
today yeah you can do it right now if
you want in fact I encourage folks to do
it right now it's uh some really awesome
work that some of my colleagues have
been working on at Ponder it's very
exciting stuff
I need to ask how easy is it to use mode
in data frames uh in machine learning
libraries like XG boost like GBM Etc
that's a really great question Aditya
and this kind of has to do a little bit
with uh two things kind of like how well
we enter we implement the interface that
Panda supports as well as our exchange
protocols so in cases where these
libraries already support using pandas
data frames natively and they have like
hooks I think it should be fairly easy
to integrate them because we support the
exact same apis pandas and if there is
an API that pandas has that we don't
have implemented in a distributed
fashion we default to pandas and what
that means is We Gather all the data
onto the head node run in pure pandas
and then distribute the thing back again
so if the library just uses pandas under
the hood it should work out of the box
if the library uses something like numpy
or something like that uh where it
requires an exchange protocol from
pandas something else again since we had
that support for the pandas API we have
these exchange protocols written you can
convert to numpy you can convert to
um you know any other type of data
representation you want and actually
boost e Matrix we have actually a custom
implementation of actually boost on top
of modem so with actually able to be
even easier to run it but it should be
fairly easy to run in fact
um I think Alejandro is uh is maybe here
right now Alejandro is our Solutions our
data Ponder and he's worked with some
folks who have used stuff like light GBM
and XG boost on top of mode and and he
could probably uh elaborate some more on
on what that experience has been like
I will say also like towards the future
we're hoping to have even more apis that
are supported on top of modem so not
just the founders API maybe you know
other really popular data science
libraries which would make it really uh
convenient to run stuff like SG boost
and like bgm GBM sorry
uh blue Tyson asks what happens if you
combine with task
sorry do you mean what happens if you
use desk with an execution engine
um I'll ask that question because I mean
that's a very interesting question if
that's not the question I apologize feel
free to ask again with a little bit more
clarification so I can understand a
little bit better
um
so if you use desk we're just using desk
as a distributed task management system
so just to handle running a cluster and
scheduling tasks uh so it would be the
same as raid be the same as any other
distributed task management system
uh if you mean like what happens if you
try and interoperate between mode and
desk
I'm not actually sure that Das supports
that I think you have to be like fully
in the desk data frame platform in order
for it to work uh but maybe we can
return to this question in a little bit
when we have some more context sorry
oh perfect yeah so Alejandro uh it was
responding to the database questions so
Alejandro solution just chimed in he
says you can install Ray on databricks
cluster by using an initialization
script then modin will take advantage of
the full cluster so yeah if you use
databricks to do cluster management it's
fairly easy to install Ray or desk on
top of that and then just run mode on
top of that
this next one is a two-parter so here's
the first part
okay I understand it covers nine percent
of API only all right oh the question is
what is the ah I see I see my bad I
totally misunderstood uh so actually I
will say that 90 number is just me
reading this graph it's actually a lot
higher in fact this is like 95 I think I
just you know it's always better to
hedge a little bit and give a lower
number right uh the 10 percent it
doesn't cover is stuff that we're
working on every day so uh one really
Salient example actually is sort so one
of the things with the distributed
education engines we use under the hood
is they're not really great for
shuffling data across partitions as you
can imagine if you have a bunch of
different nodes and they all have a
bunch of memory that they keep to
themselves they don't really want to
share data across those nodes and
Shuffle data across partitions so
operations like sort can be fairly
expensive on top of any distributed
education engine uh so that's like an
example of one of the apis that we don't
cover although I actually have a PR in
the works two natively sports sword from
modem and so say tomorrow or I guess
later today my time I'm I'm in
California so later
today Friday morning maybe Monday or
Tuesday we will actually have a little
bit higher support and we'll actually
support that but yeah uh in terms of
like what we do and don't support you
can actually check out the modern Docs
and we have a list of supported apis
right there
uh
right there yeah so you can see here
like stuff like transpose apps ads
they're all fully supported and then
like AG is like partially supported a
line is uh just
supported
uh sorry like a line of supported like
partially so this uh can help you figure
out exactly whether what you want to do
with support or not and again if it's
not supported it doesn't mean we break
we just
default to pandas and then you can
continue with your workload however
you'd like
hopefully that clarifies
awesome yeah Alexander asked a really
good question I imagine there are cases
where we must change the pandas code to
make the most of modern do you have some
general rules for that and that's a
really good question and that's actually
uh the subject of some open research
we're doing so I guess first I'll answer
the question of face value are there
cases where you need to change pandas
code to make the most emotion and the
answer is it kind of depends um
yes and no so there's cases where you
could be doing something like you know
for example iterose which is not really
efficient in a distributed computation
environment because you know we need to
transform those block partitions into
real partitions and then we have to
iterate over each row and then iterate
across the partitions and so in cases
where you're doing stuff like that it
might be better to rewrite your query
um but this is kind of the same as like
with SQL right like there's generally
like smart and not great ways to write a
query that are more or less efficient
um
in terms of do we have general rules for
that
not off the top of my head I think uh in
general well okay yes kind of so in
general you kind of want to try and
maximize parallelism however you can
right so if your accessing rows in a for
Loop right you don't necessarily want to
be doing that instead you could try like
an apply right uh the data frame apply
which is row parallel right if you're
modifying a cell at a time instead of
doing that you can try like an apply map
uh which would map over all the cells
right so in general we want to kind of
aim for those pandas apis that are the
most parallel wherever we can
um and then in terms of like the broader
question here so this is this is query
optimization right so one of the Globes
we're designing with the data frame
algebra was actually to mimic how SQL
doesn't really punish users for poor
queries right like if I if I was working
on a database and I wrote a query where
you know I did a join and then I did a
filter right like objectively that's not
the best way to write it's query right
it would be better to the filter than
the join because the cardinality of the
things I'm joining is Laura right and
under the hood the SQL database knows
this and so it's going to rewrite my
query so that we do predicate push down
right when we push the filter are up
ahead
right so with the data from algebra we
actually hope in the future to be able
to do the sort of thing with pandas
queries basically to take a penis
queries as the user writes and then
Leverage The think time where users are
inspecting the continents of the cell in
order to go like okay like I notice
they're doing a join between two data
frames and they immediately drop call a
rows where like this value is true so
let me first do the drop of the rows and
then let me do the join
uh so yeah hopefully that answers the
question Alexander and we also have the
mode in slack uh if you go to the mode
and get up page there's a or here even
if you go to the docs there's like a
link to slack and then oh that's the
pipette link I'm sorry uh that's the
slack link uh I'm not wearing my glasses
so the slack uh you can you can always
post questions like this if you have a
specific thing where you're like hey
like I'm I'm running this and it's not
really working as I expect like what do
folks think you can always post it there
and we're happy to help out always
that or delayed modem tasks on desk
compared to das data frames perhaps so
again I'm not sure I'm understanding the
question fully it sounds like perhaps
you're asking for a comparison of like
how does modem on desk work versus how
to desk data frames work perhaps like
performance wise or functionality wise
uh I will say Dash data frames require I
believe it's row partitioning I I'll
have to double check I'm not sure if it
off my head and so the operation of the
dash supports is actually fairly limited
like in that graph where we took a look
at performance you can see here uh dasc
doesn't have a median operation
right and so both in terms of
performance and in terms of like
functional like how much it can do moon
is more expressive because you don't
have to automatically manage uh
partitions in fact I was talking to
someone in the past who was using
destination to modem one of the things I
really liked about moden is moden
automatically handles how many
partitions to make and how to partition
and managing the skew of partitions
automatically right so with Das for
example you take the data and desk and
then you need to manually partition it
and if your partition gets skewed you
have to go in and be like okay look let
me rebalance these partitions in order
to make sure there's no skew in the in
the size of each partition right with
Moten we uh we have a bunch of Concepts
like virtual partitions in order to help
the user automatically rebound some
partitions onto the hood so you don't
even have to worry about partitions like
we have a heuristic for determining the
number of partitions it's basically
equal to the number of threads in your
device and then we manage you know
making block partitions making real
partitions making competitions and
making sure those partitions are roughly
evenly sized all without any worry so
there's a lot of
flexibility and there's a lot less worry
that you have to have as a mode user
than as a desk user
uh
oh Alexander has a great question on the
SQL analogy is there a way to view the
career plan that's a great question uh
so on top of the the uh the work we're
doing with modern on top of snowflake
there is a way to view this query plan
um
for now not quite this uh so okay I'll
correct myself yes and no so there is an
experimental branch of building that
we're working on uh where we do actually
formulate these query plans and we do
have in fact one of uh somebody on my
team just recently uh added a feature to
visualize these query plans but this
isn't publicly released yet just because
we're still working on some of the Kinks
with like being able to like form these
query plans and translate them to all
the algebra
uh but yes in the future like when we do
have this fully working and published uh
there will be a way to view them
interesting uh I'm not so blue test and
asked now I wonder about switching out
an x-ray I'm not familiar with x-ray it
seems like that might be an array API
um I'm happy it hits conversation
offline but I'm not familiar with x-ray
I don't think I can comment on that
also let me do this
that way if folks are interested in
checking out the QR code they can see
that